police they're not to in our community
not to motor welfare or for our security
our safety but they're there to contain
us through the lattice and murderers
this frightened the government because
this was the unity between the most
oppressed of the people in the United
States
we did what the government would not do
and they were absolutely afraid and said
we were the most dangerous the most
threatening to the internal security of
the United States
as the party grew we were more and more
stopped and surveilled by the FBI
part of the people
ah
we changed language we changed social
order we talked about the power that we
hold our slogan all power to the people
change the way people thought about
themselves we were motivated by love for
the people